ready for some Game of Thrones Season
seven spoilers No
too bad bend the knee and keep watching
because Game of Thrones of season 7
premiere was memorable for many things
like aya starts a vengeful assault on
the free family Daenerys Targaryen
finally reaching Dragonstone euron
greyjoy declaring himself for Queen
Cersei and thus an forgiving Jon Snow
some serious-ass but despite all that
season 7 already sucks you know why cuz
Joffrey's Niner I miss you Geoffrey so
much but that was all a bit overshadowed
by the Cameo of Ed Sheeran whose musical
moment on the show was unintentionally
hilarious
pretty song I've never had it was fun
the new one Sheeran stint as a Lannister
soldier might have earned a roaring a
social media response but it was just
one in a series of celebrity cameos that
have come and gone on the show here are
some other famous faces who have popped
up in the realm over the years Gary
Lightbody Sheeran was hardly the first
musician to appear on Game of Thrones in
season 3 Snow Patrol frontman Gary
Lightbody leads a battalion of house
Bolton soldiers and a rendition of the
Barons of the maiden fair in the world
of Westeros this was a folk song
everybody seems to know but in the real
world it was necessary to make audiences
aware that a song exists so that the
later episode could take that title and
run with a very literal interpretation
of it roy dotrice
if you're a longtime fan of fantasy on
television
you probably remember roy dotrice as one
Pullman's wise father figure on Beauty
and the Beast but if you're a fan of
George RR Martin's A Song of Ice and
Fire
you probably know him as a celebrated
reader of the audiobooks he was
personally chosen by Martin after the
two had worked together on Beauty and
the Beast and was originally announced
as grand maester pycelle for the HBO
series due to health reasons he was
replaced by Julian Glover but
fortunately he was able to appear in
season two as the Pyromancer Helene
while he isn't on screen much Pauline
plays a key role in Tyrion master plan
for the Battle of Blackwater so it's a
fitting use of an actor who will forever
be linked to the books David Benioff and
DB Weiss the house of black and white
where is arc receives her training of a
mystical assassin features an endless
or failed of columns lines of the faces
of the dead not statues but the actual
faces that have been removed and service
masks for the faceless men naturally the
production design staff who made the
faces ended up including people they
know most notably show creators Benioff
and Weiss whose faces occupy adjacent
compartments that receive a bit of
camera time mastered on the American
heavy metal band master Donna didn't
perform music on Game of Thrones but
they did contribute a song called white
Walker to the catch the throne volume 2
mixtape HBO released a tie-in to the
show in 2015 so it wasn't surprising
when members of the band showed up in
the episode hardhome in which they are
killed and then resurrected by the white
walkers the band can thank a game of
Thrones executive producer DB Weiss for
those collaborative opportunities
because he's apparently a big fan of the
group George W Bush in Game of Thrones
first season Sansa is made to look upon
her father's severed head by the cruel
new King Joffrey and while your eyes may
be scarred by the image of poor Lord
Stark there are tons of other spiked
heads on display alongside em including
one resembling former US President
George W Bush which rests the next two
suns a scepter many often whites
revealed that they used the already
existing head pop for the scene because
of their need for heads not for any kind
of political statement but once the word
got out some people found such a violent
depiction of a former president to be
disrespectful this led to official
apologies from HBO as well as Benny
often wife figuras
another memorable musical cameo comes at
Joffrey and Margaery wedding in season
four the Icelandic post rock band sigur
rós shows up with a strange set of
musical instruments to perform a droning
take on the House Lannister song the
rains of castamere it did not please the
king a good very good loss you go will
champion and one of the most chilling
episodes of the entire series told play
drummer will champion had joined the
cast among the drums and the halls of
the twins before all hell broke loose he
shone merrily something away as mu Tully
and his new bride ascend to their
wedding bed
blissfully unaware of the red wedding
Massacre that's about to go down
is a very strange custom Noah
syndergaard ed sheeran wasn't the only
familiar face to make his debut in
season seven New York Mets pitcher Noah
syndergaard also made a buzzy cameo in
the new season as one of house
Lannisters foot soldiers who have
incredible aim with spear throwing we
don't know if his character survived the
ensuing dragon attack but in light of
how the rest of the army fed he probably
didn't last long in the skirmish and
considering the met 2017 season he's
probably used to it thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel plus check out all
this cool stuff we know you're looking
[Applause]